Gone with the Wind Casablanca The Wizard
of Oz Citizen Kane these are some of the
most beloved films in the history of
American cinema but they all share
something else in common they were all
censored by the Catholic Church in fact
for decades there's a good chance you
didn't see anything in a Hollywood movie
unless the Catholic Church wanted you to
[Music]
Hollywood in the late 20s was chock-full
of films about pirates lovers and
monsters but not everybody was happy
about that most notably Catholics some
of whom were alarmed by what they viewed
as the crumbling morality in motion
pictures too devout Catholics a
publisher named Martin Quigley and a
Jesuit priest named father Daniel
Lourdes that's his real name
decided to do something about it in 1929
they wrote the motion picture production
code a set of proposed moral guidelines
for movies it prohibited such things as
nudity indecent dancing and ridiculing
religion while requiring the promotion
of Roman Catholic values we're good
triumphs over evil and immoral behavior
is punished
there were also slightly less folksy
provisions like barring romance between
different races as well as white slavery
yikes
when the big five Studios Warner
Brothers Paramount MGM Fox and RKO
received the guidelines they agreed to
them why would Hollywood ever willingly
sign on to censorship like this we
always have to remember that movies had
no First Amendment rights during this
time and that meant that any individual
state or municipality or by extension
the federal government could censor
motion pictures this is Thomas Doherty
and these are his slippers there are
real fears in Hollywood that Roosevelt's
New Deal government which is
proliferating government agencies with
great abandon is going to create a
federal censorship agency to censor
American movies Studios chose to adopt
it voluntarily hoping that it would
deter government interference but then
in 1930 the Great Depression hit
following the economic downturn movie
attendance tanked and studios scrambled
to do whatever it took to sell more
tickets and what sells tickets sex
violence and big-ass goblets of booze so
for a period of four years between 1932
1934 Hollywood studio films were pretty
crazy the Roman Catholics especially get
very upset by this and in late 1933 and
early 1934 they began organizing
something called believed of decency
what sounds like the lamest superhero
franchise ever actually released
publications of all Studio movies with
their accompanying rating a being
morally unobjectionable being morally
objectionable in part and see being the
dreaded condemned the legion had
something called the Legion pledge and
you have 20 million Catholics at mass
and Knights of Columbus meetings would
stand up raise their hand and pledge on
their immortal soul that they would not
attend motion pictures that the church
deemed unworthy and on holy to avoid a
devastating boycott Hollywood created
the production code administration to
enforce the guidelines and appointed
devout Catholic Joseph Breen as its head
here's Edward Herrmann playing him in
the aviator and I can state
categorically that I've never seen
anything quite so unacceptable the Breen
office would get a script from a studio
and he would go through them line by
line to make sure that nothing was said
or implied or visualized that defied the
production code for instance here's a
couple of their notes on the Jimmy
Stewart film It's a Wonderful Life page
21 while it will be acceptable to
indicate Gower as having recourse to
drink because of his disturbing
emotional problem we must pass that he
not be shown at any time offensively
drunk here or throughout the scenes this
is important page 37
the action of Harry slapping a knee on
the
is unacceptable page 38 this reference
to impotency is unacceptable the Green
Office approved every aspect of a film
you know every image every line of
dialogue add Nats marketing costumes and
it really makes him one of the most
powerful men in Hollywood history and by
extension made his office one of the
most influential in Hollywood if you
look in the credits of every Hollywood
film from 1934 to 1954 you can see the
PCA logo without it your movie didn't
stand a chance the PCA got to say which
movies the studios could make and since
the studio's own many of the theaters in
the country most audiences only had
access to production code films you
could almost call this arrangement a
monopoly and some people did nine people
to be exact
us first Paramount Pictures was a
landmark antitrust court case in 1948 in
which the Supreme Court said this kind
of monopoly was illegal and forced the
studio's to sell their theaters since
the studio's could no longer control was
shown it opened up the floodgates for
independent and European films neither
of which needed to abide by the code the
PCA quietly existed until 1967 when the
Motion Picture Association of America
took over and American film switched
over to a rating system so III always
see the code is something that's not
good or bad but something that is
inevitable and it allowed them to create
a lot of great art I don't I mean if you
you look at the movies made under the
production code I mean we're talking
about what hundreds of marvelous
creative works of art that people still
look at today if you feel like today's
movies are just missing something you're
not alone our sister site polygon
explored the massive explosion in CGI in
today's movies so go check it out and
stick around if you're a fan of video
games in pop culture